I mean you know the way it ended I'm not
sure that I don't I don't know how
you're around are you around the truth
is Lawrence gone for good on HBO's
insecure Jay Ellis spoke to et at
Esquires Mavericks of Hollywood
celebration in LA on Tuesday and we have
some concerns so many people are excited
about season 3 what cuties what can we
expect I don't know anything about
season pearl I'm a hundred percent
positive I know not it's seriously not
one single thing I mean you know the way
it ended I'm not sure that I don't I
don't know that you're around are you
around I don't know but I just the way
it ended there was some closure there
you wouldn't think that I would be
around right judging by the smile I'm
thinking I'm just saying like you know
you know I think that it's a real like
part of life when you have that kind of
closure like you typically never see
that person again so fingers crossed I
might have just given something away
okay all right well my fingers are
crossed I want to see you back back
you